I'm in the mood to improve my flexibility
a little bit so I decide to take some Yoga classes
so I show up at the local yoga place called Super Yoga
and ask them, "how much does it cost?"
And they say, "we've got a basic plan"
"and we've got a trial plan."
The trial plan, if you just want to try things out,
you can come to any of the sessions
and it's going to cost you $12 per 1hr session.
but if you like what you're doing here
you might want to get a monthly membership
That'll be $20/month,
that you can view that as the basic plan
It's $20/month and then you get a discount per session
It'll only be $8 per session
So this seems interesting, but I'm a little bit confused.
Which plan should I take?
So the first place, I might start is to think about
how much I would pay
depending on how many sessions I actually take
And to do a little short hand here
let's just define some variables
Let's say that S = "Number of Sessions" I attend per month
Number of sessions per month that I attend
I decided to attend at Super Yoga
And let's say that C = "Total Monthly Cost"
My Total Monthly Cost
So with these variables defined this way,
let's think about how much I would pay
under each of these plans
depending on how many sessions I would attend
So first, let's think about the, we'll start with the Trial Plan
cause that seems a little simplier
and I'll draw a little column here
I have a cost, actually, let me see, I'll draw my number of sessions
Number of sessions and then I have my cost
and then I'm going to draw a little table here
A little table, that'll be for my trial plan
and then let's also do the same thing,
since we're doing it for the trial plan
let's do it for the basic plan so that we can compare
Let's do it for the basic plan
so I have the Number of sessions I attend
and my Total Cost
So let's first think about, if I decide to attend no sessions
So if I decided to attend no sessions
under my trial plan, what will be my cost?
Well, $12 per session, 12 x no sessions
Well, I'm not going to have to pay anything
My cost is going to be zero
Now what about that same question
under the basic plan
If I have the basic plan, but in a given month
I attend no sessions,
I don't go to the gym, I don't go to this yoga gym at all
How much am I going to have to pay?
Well, it's $8 per sessions
I didn't have to go to any sessions
So I'm not going to have to pay anything
on a per session basis
but I will have to pay that $20/month
So I will have to pay $20
even though I didn't even attend
That doesn't seem so good in that scenario
But let's keep working through other scenarios
Let's think about the scenario where I attend 1 session
Where I attend 1 session
Under the trial plan, how much will I have to pay?
Well, it's $12/session x 1 session
I'm going to pay $12
Let's think about that same scenario under the basic plan
Under the basic plan, if I attend 1 session
Well, it's $8/session x 1 session
$8 for that
Plus just the basic monthly
So I'm just going to have to pay $20 + ($8 x 1)
So $28.
I'm going to have to pay $28
So still that trial plan still looks pretty good
even if I attend 1 session
Let me make it clear
That's in dollars
and that over here is $28
and I could keep going
and I encourage you to keep going
but let's try 1 more
just to see how, just to get a feel for the numbers here
If I attend 2 sessions under the trial plan
How much am I going to pay?
Well, it's $12/session x 2 sessions
i'm going to pay $24
Let's think about the basic plan
if I attend 2 sessions
-- let me do that in a yellow colour --
2 x $8/session, that's going to $16
plus the $20 I'm going to have to spend every month
So it's going to 2 x $8
+ $20
= $16 + $20
= $36
So at least for the scenarios that we set up here
if I attend 0 or 1 or 2 sessions
the trial plan seems to be winning out
but I want to explore at what point
does the trial plan actually become a little bit worse
But before we do that
let's think about if we can represent this
this a little algebraically
because it's going to allow us to be a little bit more precise
with coming up with our answers
So if we say that, S is the "Number of Sessions per Month"
and C is the "Monthly Cost"
How can we express the trial plan as an equation?
Well, we could say our Total Cost
our Total Monthly Cost
so this is for our trial plan right over here
let me draw a dotted line over here to show
well, the dotted line goes around there
so under the trial plan our total cost is going to be equal to
well, it's $12/session x # of sessions
times S
So under the trial plan I could say my total cost is equal to
$12 x # of Sessions
$12/session x the Number of Sessions
Let's so the same thing with the basic plan
How can we express that as an equation?
Well, we have our total cost
our total cost is going to be equal to
well, regardless of what we do
any given month, we're going to have to pay
the $20/month
we're going to have to pay that 20
So no matter what we do,
just from the get-go
and then we're going to pay $8/session
so it's going to be $20 + ($8 x # of Sessions)
so that's interesting and you can see
if you put S is 0 here,
if you make S = 0
you get 20 + (8 x 0) which is 20
if you say S is 1, you get 20 + (8 x 1)
which is 28
so you see that each of these S's and C's
they satisfy this equation
Same thing over here
and we can keep trying more and more
What's neat about these equations is
just this equation encapsulates
all of the possible combinations here
and just this equation encapsulates
all the possible combinations there
and so for the next few videos,
what I want to do is explore
How can we use these equations
to come up with more insights as to
which plan is better for me